you know what science is it's a
professional way of querying nature
so that you can not fool yourself into
thinking something is true that is not
or that something is not true that is if
you say something is true let me test it
let me let me find out let me devise an
experiment and if I can verify your
statement with this experiment and
someone else can in a third person we're
good here that's an objective truth and
what objective truths have going for
them is that they're true whether or not
you believe in them I don't like them
well because the actual nature can't be
fooled nature is the ultimate judge jury
and executioner yeah if you're going to
create laws in a pluralistic world you
base the laws on the objective truths
right because that applies to everyone
don't base a law on your personal truth
because that's forcing it on me and I
have a different personal truth is
climate change and objective truth oh
yes
oh yes so what happens is you believe in
climate change it's not a belief it's
not about a belief right it's but it's
when it's objectively true you don't
have to believe it it just is true yeah
I believe in it when it's really hot I
believe in it it's like a hot day I'm
like damn they're right they're right
about oh [ __ ]
I'm serious dude so I'm like we gotta
fight this so so here's the thing so so
if it was only determined that way then
another person that was in a cold snap
would say no I don't believe it right
and everybody's making up their own
theories about it because they're it's
their own life experience but an
experiment
takes the information out of yourself
okay it's not your perspective it's not
your bias it's not your world view and
you get all the data available and then
you establish the objective truth in the
last 20 years
um there are basically no scientists
left denying it so it's basically 100
damn right one hold out right there but
let's go back to when it was three
percent because that's a fun number okay
all right let's do an experiment there's
a bridge that's there you don't know
where it came from but it's a bridge but
it's brand new and it's about to open
and you say I want to drive my truck
across the bridge 97 Engineers come up
to you and say if you drive a truck
that's going to collapse and you're
going to die you'll likely die plunging
into the Ravine so 97 of them say that
three say oh Theo go take your F-150
drive across you're some good old boys
never mean it no harm
going
fine
what are you gonna do probably listen to
the 97 Engineers especially if you're
not an engineer yourself yeah I'm
thinking if you got to look the
engineers in the eyes now no ice got
nothing to do with this that's you
trying to be human about this oh don't
be human that mess you up
let me feel what you're saying no
they'll show you the research papers
there's no eyeballs in the research
paper there's no emoticons in the
research paper so then what is that that
makes me want to look him in the eyes
and see what is that if you look someone
in the eye and they tell you something
that just happened
that is more true to you
than a statistical table with charts
right bar charts then a pie graph then a
pie graph that says the same [ __ ]
thing the eyewitness testimony
has huge value to our emotions because
another human being is communicating it
right do whatever it takes to not fool
yourself into thinking something is true
that is not or that something is not
true that is doesn't mean getting a
video of it does it mean getting a
getting someone else to check on you did
you have your coffee this morning or not
is that the measure were you more alert
did you miss something right do whatever
it takes and when you do that it ain't
got nothing to do with the passion in
their eyes oh
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one